اعلنوا انني اجزت اول عمليه نقل اصول
روسيه المصادره لاستخدامها لصالح اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وامرت محكمه في نيويورك بمصادره الاموال
صالح الولايات المتحده وبتفويض مني ستحول
هذه الاموال الى الخارجيه لتستخدم في اطار
دعم الشعب الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
نشهد اليوم التصديق على تحويل اصول
المصادره بقيمه خمسه ملايين واربع مئه الف
دولار الى وزاره الخارجيه لاستخدامها
لصالح اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا التي دمرتها
الحرب
[موسيقى]
عقوبات متماسكه وسنستمر في زيادتها وجعلها
اكثر قسوه حسب الاقتضاء هذه العقوبات
ستكون قاسيه وباقيه ما دام هذا العدوان
مستمرا
[موسيقى]
الاجراءات غير القانونيه التي فرضت على
روسيا سببت لنا صعوبات هذه حقيقه واضحه
لكن هذه الصعوبات ليس كما كان يخطط لها
المبادرون بشن حرب اقتصاديه خاطفه ضد
روسيا